hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play sega tzu chi
or whatever this is called we started in
a rather disconcerting area because
there are mannequins like everywhere and
i don't know why but anyway we're gonna
move forward here umm someone told me
that this was a type of Slenderman game
because I remember that picture from
something in the Sun um in mythos and I
don't really remember anymore but I'm
just kind of disturbed by this this is
actually a really well made game on the
Unreal development kit and I um confused
more than anything ooh that is a pretty
painting with dead bodies flailing
everywhere that's lovely ok and I'm I
hear something or was that outside I
have no idea anyway um I'm still in
South Carolina as you could tell and I'm
still making videos with sin ago which
is going awesomely if you haven't seen
them already checkouts Indigo's channel
ok I'm back at the mannequin room again
so yeah about this I need to find eight
pages but I'm in a building now as
opposed to being outside somewhere kind
of confused because I got the amnesia
lantern going on hi why are you in there
I have no idea or did I need to find
keys I've kind of distracted by they I
don't know
mannequins everywhere for no wait
there's something in there
is that a page ok that's a page that I
need but I don't know how to get into
there um just kind of taking any
environment for now because this is
awfully disturbing I like it in a lot of
ways because it's a different take I'm
true when I've seen before on Slenderman
games and I mean slender is kind of run
its course in a lot of ways but at the
same time it still can be made fresh
I've gone in there this is like a tiny
area what am I supposed to do I am
hearing something ok I'm not going crazy
I'm hearing something there's something
here but I don't have keys hello
want to be my friend you want to die in
a fire ok here we go got this open why
there's nothing in here well one of
these doors open but there's nothing
here so ok hi can you alright fine [ __ ]
off then what are you looking at looking
at the game I'm Stu Daniels right here
you know my shoulder so yeah cyndago
everybody Cindy goes here and watch
their channel subscribe to them
alright so anyway back to the game I'm
seriously out of losses what I'm
supposed to do here because I the only
one of these that I've actually gotten
to open has nothing in it I've seen nary
a hint Norris smell of any Slenderman ok
I hear that what is that getting louder
ok ok now I'm breathing heavy and I'm
obviously a girl so now my lanterns
going out it's happening I see her sake
in beer huh
Elena went out why do I let her go out
why do I let her go out but I run out of
time why I can't see anything
who's that close the window ok I can see
the sky kinda what am I supposed to do
the wooden pillar there's this
mannequins everywhere that are gonna pop
out of the darkness and I'm gonna see
where ok I hit a wall something I can't
see can slow never just come and find me
and kill me so they can start over
because I would really oh did my lantern
recharge and it's back now good ok ok
that's still locked this is still
frickin locked this is still locked as
if it page in there whatever I don't
know I don't care I want to go home what
am i doing why am i doing it and why can
I only run for two inches at a time
the ultimate questions that I asked
myself over and over and over in every
game that I ever play why why why why
why this why this I haven't seen a
Slendy man so I don't even think he
exists in this game just waiting ok hi
was there something there was that just
static there's actually something gonna
happen whoa I said I found it I got a
key sweet that was hard to find but okay
now I got a plate find which cell it
goes to Oh son of a I don't want to free
the mannequin why would I want to do
that do the keys there a hidden in the
nooks and crevices ooh
oh it was to the front door okay okay
now I'm outside wow that took forever Oh
what the hell Oh Oh could I have opened
that a long time ago I'm sorry why why
why why why why why why why why I do
this I do this to me good oh come on I
don't wanna be here I don't I do
anything I want to go home please this
is very Japanese inspired by the way as
if you couldn't tell by the name of the
video there's a lit with some I don't
even know how to pronounce it but these
are like oriental themed rooms here
they're a page I haven't even found one
page my life it's alive hang on let me
put out my torch so I can recharge my
lantern I'm it generate oil by squirting
it out of my nipples I don't know shut
up
okay there was a fruitless endeavor into
nothingness so I'm happy that I did that
sure stop squirting oil out of your
nipples it's not gonna help me I don't
want any of it okay I'm out in the woods
and there's nothing here okay can I just
go in the woods find one page one I
would love to find just one page one
page would be amazing I want to actually
see Slenderman what is sentiment in
Japan I don't know that sat in my head
what was that in real life I have no
idea I'm hearing noises now and that's
usually not a good sign
I'm hearing more birds you hearing birds
I hearing birds okay my lantern is
almost out of lantern juice a lot okay
boo what why why why why why why why why
so many times I asked the question why
okay please just jump one page just one
just one how why where am I now
ah what why is he here is this
Slenderman is he gonna get me he's gonna
get me oh that's a good effect yeah okay
oh that was amazing total times 7:30
look at Slenderman for less than one
minute of what what does that even mean
what times men reach or what time spent
in closets times exhausted I didn't find
a single page damn it
alright I gotta read try that before it
beats my ass Integra you enjoying
yourself just trying to not be and more
oh I started in somewhere else okay
whispering over there shut up okay all
right so I started somewhere else I'm
getting annoyed at this game more than
anything that Slenderman was terrible
that was like the worst Slenderman I've
ever seen in my life so hopefully there
will be something else and I apparently
the mechanic of this game is that you
need to recharge your lanterns so great
that makes total sense and glad that's
happening now I'm just wandering through
the trees looking for dope 'add page or
a key or something to shove up
salinities button find it I don't know
synagogues like messing with my mind
they got like 10,000 gay jokes and like
one good joke and that's all they do
so you heard me you heard what I said
that's all cynical is I wish I wish we
had a camera of the behind the scenes
well every day at the end of every take
it's just bond all the balls whatever
all right know that you know it's true
okay whatever anyway besides all that
we're still shut up I'm trying to play a
Slendy man game and I have no idea
shook that good never mind
okay I've reached the edge of the woods
and I still have found nothing I am
about ready to give up in this game
because I'm at first it was really cool
because the atmosphere would bring me in
but now like now that I realize that the
game is weird and totally confusing
I have no incentive to move forward and
I'm like totally at a loss I don't know
what to do like I wanted I went into the
came wanting to like this game but I'm
not gonna say it's a bad game there are
some interesting mechanics to it but at
the same time it's rather I don't know
tedious tedious is a good word to
describe this because you can't run fast
at all you can't run far at all your
lantern recharges why not just make it a
flashlight if that is the case and I
don't know I'm times gonna know when
things don't make sense this is a big
tree Oh splash I'm in the water now why
I'm in the water
there better be something on this tree
okay this is a gigantic tree and it has
a page on it took the children of you I
never said you were gay I said you acne
and there's nothing wrong with being gay
one good joke personally great videos
I'm just okay don't worry about a thing
okay so I found Slenderman that was cool
and all and how I'm completely out of
the atmosphere of the game so alright
alright I'll ride out ride gonna learn
today everything Kevin Hart Kevin are
you gonna learn today
shut up in me Lord I was the one sucking
dick for money
alright I'll ride out ride that's my
favorite word okay hi Slenderman
oh yeah that's terrifying
okay all right there was obviously a lot
of things wrong with this game but at
the same time I was kinda tracted
because Daniel Bryan are here making me
laugh off screen so hard to play horror
games like this but anyway so thank you
all so much for watching if you want to
play the game for yourself check the
description it's always there thank you
again and as always I will see you
[Music]